and welcome to hannity tonight we begin
again with a fox news alert tonight
russian forces they have been repelled
from ukraine's capital city once again
after an important suburb outside of
kiev was retaken by ukrainian soldiers
during a counter-attack meanwhile the
besieged city we've been telling you
about mario paul continues to hold out
tonight despite horrific conditions on
the ground there are reports and
president zielinski is out there saying
this entire city has been decimated the
rest of ukraine remains in a virtual
standstill and this as reports emerged
that russian soldiers are now running
short on food and gas and other basic
supplies we could always hope as
thousands sadly of casualties mount
vladimir putin's invasion is not going
as planned and now many western
officials fear the worst including
potential biological and chemical
weapons attacks now we've got to stop
right here
uh because vladimir putin keeps making
nuclear threats chemical
weapons of threats bio-weapon threats
joe biden and all of our nato allies
need to stop cowering at the words of
vladimir putin he makes a threat and you
bubble and fizz like alka-seltzer in
water uh in other words you're being
intimidated you're allowing yourself to
be intimidated and you're acting and
looking kind of gutless
lead all of our allies joey and strongly
tell putin that you're all united and if
he does cross that line and it's a
chemical biological or god forbid
nuclear attack god forbid any of these
attacks he will be met with a response
ten times worse for him do we want that
of course we don't want that his troops
and russia will then be in the
crosshairs uh if he crosses that line
where nato nations are impacted whatever
you say
you need to do so know that fact too
now because putin's spokesperson won't
rule out even the news use of nuclear
weapons well take a look for yourself
president putin has laid that card on
the table president putin said that if
anybody tries to stop him very bad
things will happen and i want to know
whether you are convinced or confident
that your boss will not use
that option
well we have a
concept of uh domestic security
and uh well it's public you can read all
the reasons
for nuclear
arms to be used
so if it is an ex
existing
threat for our country
then it can be used in accordance with
our concept
now obviously it has to be taken very
seriously vladimir putin is backed into
a corner he's been embarrassed on the
world stage he's anxious clearly
paranoid angry god only knows what he'll
do next he's had no problem killing
innocent men women and children and by
the way nato not only the u.s not the
u.s alone
they need to spell out what the
immediate consequences would be because
those
weapons of war would trigger article 5
of the nato alliance now putin's
soldiers have already leveled entire
towns they've blown up women and
children's hospitals they've bombed
playgrounds they've bombed schools
they've shot peaceful protesters in the
light of day shot ukrainians waiting in
a breadline and used cluster bombs and
of course their uh hypersonic weapon
to show off to the world as well now the
u.s embassy in kiev is accusing russia
of kidnapping over 2 000 ukrainian
children and shipping them across the
border into russia so ask yourself what
is stopping putin from escalating this
war even further with chemical or
biological weapons i hope he doesn't but
the question is is the west is nato is
joe ready to respond if he does do you
have confidence in joe biden's ability
to respond appropriately because i don't
now yesterday after another long weekend
in delaware riding his little bicycle
around town joe was babbling about
something he referred to as the new
world order take very close note of this
you know we are at an inflection point i
believe in the world economy not just
the world economy in the world it occurs
every three or four generations
as one of them as the one of the top
military people said to me in a secure
meeting the other day
60 60 million people died between 1900
and 1946
and
since then we established a liberal
world order and that hadn't happened in
a long while a lot of people died but
nowhere near the chaos
and now is a time when things are
shifting we're gonna they're gonna be a
new world order out there and we've
gotta lead it and we've gotta unite the
rest of the free world in doing it
allow me to translate this is a tip of
the hat to biden's climate alarmist
religious called new green deal social
space instead of putting america first
and making america great again uh we
will be all asked to sacrifice more and
more and live more simple communal lives
together in order to somehow save mother
earth this is not some kind of vast
right-wing conspiracy if you recall last
year biden vowed to fundamentally change
our economy on the campaign trail he
told voters he told you that he would
end fossil fuels well he's following up
on that promise he promised to kill the
keystone pipeline he did he banned
drilling on federal lands auctions on
federal lands he ended exploration in
anwar he praised the green new deal
incorporated all of it into his bernie
biden manifesto and now you the american
people are paying four or five bucks a
gallon for gasoline and by the way
congratulations to los angeles tonight
because the average cost for a gallon of
gasoline is officially average cost over
six bucks all while america's enemies
they're getting rich now instead of
generating our own energy with our vast
natural resources here at home well new
world order joe is making deals with
countries that we know hate us including
sending emissaries to venezuela to talk
to the murdering dictator thug there
maduro uh he's talking with iranian
mueller's in a deal brokered by russia
does that make any sense to you the
result is a compromise national security
and what do we have a 40-year inflation
high great job joe now if you're not on
board then you're likely probably one of
those evil capitalists that believe in
the word profit and you probably want
dirty air and dirty water and you want
children to die and you want some
republican to throw your grandmother or
grandfather in a wheelchair over the
cliff that's biden's new world order if
you're an enemy of america let's sit
down make a deal that's horrible for
america we sacrifice for the planet
earth while china india iran opec russia
and all the other countries that hate
our guts they carry on with business as
usual joe drives up the the cost of a
barrel of oil and they're making
billions this is what america last
policies look like and by the way in
addition to making us less safe less
secure less prosperous it's also a huge
scam clean energy great idea but at this
point in time windmills solar plants
solar solar panels they are not capable
of powering this country the lifeblood
of the world's economy is oil gas and
coal the less oil the less gas we
produce at home the more we have to
import from overseas they get rich we
pay more at the end of the day when it
comes to mother earth is it really
better for the environment that we drill
a barrel of oil in russia or the middle
east or venezuela or iran than in the
u.s and canada can anyone in the climate
alarmist religious cult can you give me
an honest answer does it really matter
where the oil comes from does it make
that big a difference because it's in
our best national security interest to
drill here drill now because every
american will save money it's good for
our national security it'll create great
jobs high-paying career jobs in the
energy sector uh also when you look at
all the other benefits that would drop
inflation dramatically in this country
and on the other end of it if we can
even produce more and be a net exporter
of energy like we were under donald
trump we could help out our western
european and nato allies at the end of
the day biden's war on fossil fuels
impacts more than just the price at the
pump think about this the high cost of
crude oil natural gas is now funding
vladimir putin's war because without
that revenue an attack on ukraine would
not have been possible now much of
ukraine has been completely destroyed
thousands of innocent people have died
millions of lives have been upended
likely forever and sadly the situation
in ukraine will get worse before it does
get ever ever has a chance of getting
better hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else